(harmonica music)
(group laughs)
- Martin, join us for tea.
Gentlemen.
- Drink up.
- Governor.
Drink up.
- Oh, that tastes awful.
- Cuz it's mushroom tea.
(Betsy laughs)
- (group) Oh!
- You've been boinked.
- You need to burp?
- Wait, wait you.
(group claps)
- I've never done
mushrooms before.
- Best do it with
people you trust.
- Mhm.
- What do you guys say we
adjourn to the mushroom room?
(Betsy laughs)
- Alright.
- Yes.
- Wait, hang on, like
what's, gonna hap.
Betsy, Betsy, what's gonna.
- Gimme that.
♪ Betsy, gimme that
♪ Cornell give me that
♪ Cornell
♪ Betsy again
- Oh God.
I don't wanna become
one of those guys
who has to like spend the
rest of his life in a home,
thinking he's glass
of orange juice.
- Oh, relax Martin.
You're in a safe place.
- Maybe Martin should grow some
balls before he can trip em.
(group laughs)
- Suck it, community
college boy.
(group laughs)
(guy growls)
- Okay, that was fun.
Guys, just relax now.
Picture yourselves on
a canoe or a gondola,
like something from Venice.
A very imposing black
man is steering the ship.
His face is serene.
There's nothing to ruin
the oneness of your total--
- Oh, hey guys!
Cool candles.
Hey, you know what, I
would love to join you,
but I got a 4pm skype date,
so maybe I'll join
you when I'm finished.
So, um, enjoy your circle party.
It looks cool.
- Circle,
cake,
party,
oh party circle.
Damn it, damn it!
That reminds me it's my
boss's birthday tonight
and I was supposed to
bake three dozen cupcakes!
- That reminds me my step-dad's
getting married tomorrow
and I'm supposed to
lose four pounds tonight
so I can fit into the tuxedo.
- A ten year old is interviewing
me about George Washington
in an hour.
- [All Three] None of us
should be tripping right now!
(group screams)
- Oh, come on.
Come on, Martin.
Come on.
Drop that shit, let's go.
(crickets)
- This,
here we go.
Okay, alright, ah Jesus.
♪ And as the sun and the trees
♪ Sway in blissful harmony
- I don't know what this
bitch Crocker is saying.
Okay, what is she writing?
You know what?
I'm just gonna
chop up some eggs.
♪ Sing ourselves to sleep
♪ While we drift along the sea
- Yeah, yeah,
yes.
You want some of that?
♪ And the leaves gather
♪ Far as eyes can see
♪ Where
- Put this in the oven.
Yeah, yeah.
- One,
fifty-two
I can't do it anymore, man,
my arms feel like screams.
You're right.
If I stop now, I'm no
better than my real dad.
(doorbell rings)
- Hey, Timmy, I'm
so fucking excited
to teach you about
George Washington.
Ask me anything.
- What year did Washington
cross the Delaware?
- (crying) I don't know.
I don't know.
- Oh, mix you
beautiful bastard, mix.
(alarm beeps)
Ow, ow, oh well.
- I'm doing a hundred
laps in each room.
Energy is everything.
- Go!
Come on, I'm putting
them in now boys.
- Timmy's here.
This kid doesn't know shit
about American history
and I think he's a Communist.
- Universal healthcare. (barks)
(guys scream)
I think I'm gonna go.
- Where do you think
you're going, Lenin?
I don't want to do this to you!
(phone buzzes and rings)
- I think my pants
are vibrating.
- Oh, what's that sound?
It's driving me crazy.
- It's coming from
Martin's dick.
- His dick's a robot!
- Kill it!
Please kill my dick.
♪ And as the sun and the trees
♪ Sway in blissful harmony
♪ As we sing our--
- We must protect the boy.
He's humanity's last hope.
Come on.
Sh, sh, sh,
it's okay.
Come here.
Heroes don't cry.
(guys scream)
♪ As the sun and the trees
- This looks like a fun party.
♪ As we sing ourselves to sleep
♪ While drifting
(birds chirp)
- Hey man, you alright?
You were pretty
wasted last night.
- What happened?
- Well, everything
pretty much worked out.
Betsy got a raise at work,
Nick has washboard abs,
and Timmy got an
A+ on his report.
- Huh, after all that?
- Yeah, everything pretty
much worked out for everyone.
Right, Cornell?
- I'm not Cornell. I'm
glass of orange juice.
(guys scream)
♪ As the sun and the trees
♪ Sway in blissful harmony
- And my name's Cornell.
- No, no, no
- Come back!
Come back!
- This tastes weird.